and a granddaughter would find it a lot
more difficult to become a boss than a
grandson and she probably earned less to
the latest statistics on the male-female
divide when it comes to pay packets it's
pretty hard to misinterpret let's have a
look a study by the World Economic Forum
revealed last year women on average
still earned only a little over half of
what men earned and here to tell us more
about that very topic is henryka phone
platen she found it the Fair Pay
Innovation Lab then welcome to the
studio what are the reasons for that
disparity how big is this gender pay gap
really leverage gender pay gap is 21%
and you have a lot of reasons in there
that are very basically structural
reasons being in what you call part-time
jobs or the role stereotypes problems so
you have these reasons in that gap and
if you take the reasons out and look at
them in detail you will get to a gap of
say 2 to 8% which cannot be explained
and for us it's very very important that
we start to really work on these
structural issues why is it that the
child care or care for other elderly
family members ends up in the hands of
women and why is it not remunerated well
in the tradition some hundred years ago
women used to do those jobs already and
they didn't get paid at all it wasn't
used to being a paid job later on
it went into being a paid job and you
got some kind of pocket money you could
say for it and now it's a real job that
you learn for and you're doing it and
it's sort of this historical tradition
that makes it put that sort of puts it
into this corner of being very very
badly paid which is the same if men work
in that job too so it's a matter of a
society to really think about is it fair
is it the way that we want to live
paying these jobs so badly compared to
paying for example people who care for
our cars a lot better look at another
study from the World Economic Forum it
shows that women actually also work
longer hours than men on average they
clock up more than eight and a half
hours a day that's almost 50 minutes
more than the
man and over half of that labor is
unpaid things like as we've mentioned
child care a housework men clearly spent
much less time on those tasks so and we
could do we need to force men by legal
means to do their part and taking care
of children to take care of their
parents for example I think the measures
of the parent taking the Parenthood like
half half each which I think is very
good you have to make sure that the
parents can decide freely how they live
and work and by giving them the
opportunity to sort of take that part in
half both have the chance to really sort
of say well I do my part of the unpaid
work and I give the other partner the
chance to be painful isn't that the
choice that families have to make for
themselves so do we need to force them
well the problem is said it's not a real
choice if you think about two people
trying to decide who will stay at home
to care for the kids it's usually not
the woman just because it's a choice but
because she's the one earning less so if
you want to have a wage or a family
money for the month that you can sort of
live off you will usually tend to let
the person stay at home that earns less
and that gives you this vicious cycle of
which you need to get out in a way what
can companies do if they want to do
anything what they do a lot about
talking about money and being
transparent that what they need to do if
they need to do a lot more on that they
usually do programs that people cannot
stay at home lots of companies cared for
the father's to stay at home and they
have like programs saying that they
should they're not enough companies
doing that often the companies sort of
tend to take it not so seriously so we
need a lot to do that
Alif important thank you very much